você sabia que algo tão simples quanto
uma caneca de caldo de ossos por dia
pode revolucionar sua saúde imagine
melhorar sua digestão fortalecer o
sistema imunológico revitalizar os seus
músculos e aliviar dores articulares
inflamações com apenas uma ação diária
ao incorporar o caldo de osso em sua
rotina diária você também garante uma
dose poderosa de colágeno essencial para
fortalecer tendões ossos e PR
principalmente suas articulações isso
significa mais saúde menos dor no seu
dia a dia olá tudo bem aqui Dr Lan
Machado Dutra para mais um vídeo Não
deixe de acompanhar esse conteúdo até o
final esse caldo é preparado utilizando
partes de animais que normalmente são
descartadas como ossos pele pés tendões
e ligamentos esses componentes embora
não sejam comestíveis de forma isolada
contribuem de forma significativa pra
riqueza nutricional do caldo quando
cozido Então qual é a composição
nutricional desse caldo tem diferentes
tipos de caldo de ossos como de galinha
ou de boi eles todos são fontes ricas de
vários nutrientes essenciais conté
aminoácidos importantes como glicina
arginina e prolina vitaminas e minerais
diversos é fonte riquíssima de colágeno
eletrólitos e até glucosamina que
protege as nossas articulações a glicina
que é um componente chave do colágeno
juntamente com a prolina e lanina são
aminoácidos que são fundamentais paraa
construção da Matriz do tecido conectivo
que é responsável pelo suporte do corpo
então esses aminoácidos são utilizados
pelo corpo para reparar áreas que
sofreram desgaste e estresse sendo
essenciais para manutenção e Recuperação
de tecidos Além disso o colágeno do
Calde ossos é enriquecido com
aminoácidos que possuem propriedades
anti-inflamatórias contribuindo paraa
saúde geral e longevidade vamos falar
então dos benefícios à saúde que vem do
causo de ossos número um promoção da
Saúde intestinal porque esse causo de
ossos atou como elixir devido a sua rica
concentração de colágeno que é
fundamental pra integridade e manutenção
do revestimento intestinal então a
gelatina resultante da quebra do
colágeno durante o cozimento dos Ossos
contém aminoácidos que auxiliam na
reparação de junções danificadas no
intestino melhorando o caso de intestino
hiper permeável fortalecendo as
membranas mucosas saudáveis e prevenindo
o vazamento de partículas não digeridas
e substâncias químicas que vão acabar
indo pra corrente sanguínea além disso a
gelatina formada pela quebra do colágeno
contém aminoácidos que suportam D
suporte à digestão para indivíduos com
alergias alimentares e sensibilidades
promovendo um ambiente favorável ao
equilíbrio e crescimento de probióticos
das bactérias boas nos intestinos a
ingestão de cald de ossos vai estar
associado à redução de problemas
digestórios comuns como inchaço gases
refluxo ácido diarreia e constipação
Graças aos seus nutrientes que dão
suporte apoio o bom funcionamento do
sistema digestório número dois
benefícios para pele cabelos e unhas
alta disponibilidade de colágeno no Cao
de ossos reflete diretamente na saúde da
pele dos cabelos e unhas porque esse
colágeno vai promover a renovação
celular Vai resultar em pele mais
elástica firme hidratada fortalecendo
cabelos e unhas o terceiro ponto é rico
em minerais essenciais Então por ser
preparado por ossos e partes animais
ricas em minerais O Causo de osso é uma
fonte excelente de cálcio de fósforo de
magnésio potássio e sulfatos que são
cruciais pro equilíbrio eletrolítico
paraa saúde óssea pro funcionamento
muscular e nervoso prevenindo
desidratação e outros equilíbrios em
populações vulneráveis como é o caso dos
idosos o quarto ponto é desintoxicação
do fígado do sistema digestório o caldo
de osso vai ajudar a aumentar os níveis
de glutationa que é um potente
antioxidante que dá suporte à função do
fígado na remoção de toxinas e resíduos
metabólicos com ajuda de aminoácidos
como o caso da glicina o quinto ponto é
o fortalecimento do sistema de defesa do
sistema imune consumir o caldo de osso
pode melhorar a fla intestinal e por
extensão fortale seu sistema de defesa
imune uma flora intestinal saudável está
diretamente ligada a uma melhor Resposta
imune além de impactar de forma positiva
outros aspectos como equilíbrio hormonal
e controle de peso o sexto ponto é o
auxílio na perda de peso O Causo de osso
pode normalizar o apetite controlar
hormônios relacionados à fome como a
grelina além de estimular a secreção do
hormônio de crescimento humano que é
vital para a queima de gordura então a
auxilia na redução dos níveis de
triglicerídeos sétimo ponto melhoria do
sono e redução da ansiedade que a
glicina que esse aminoácido presente em
grandes quantidades no caldo de osso tem
mostrado que melhora a qualidade do Sono
reduz a ansiedade e também aprimora a
função cognitiva e memória o oitavo
ponto é prevenção da perda muscular o
causo de ócio é rico em aminoácidos
essenciais que vão ajudar na síntese do
hormônio do crescimento
e a manutenção da massa muscular Isso
vai ser importante especialmente para
prevenir a sarcopenia com envelhecimento
que é a perda de massa muscular nono
ponto é o alívio de Dores articulares
porque a glucosamina é condroitina que
estão na cartilagem dos ossos que são
liberados durante o cozimento eles são
conhecidos por suas propriedades de
alívio de dor redução na inflamação das
articulações e vão ajudar casos de
osteoartrite formação das ul ações o
décimo ponto é recuperação acelerada de
resfriados e gripes por causa de ossos
que é especialmente o preparado com
ossos de frango contém cisteína que
ajuda a fluidificar o muo dos pulmões
facilitando a sua expulsão acelerando a
recuperação de resfriados e de gripes
Então vamos falar aqui Como fazer o
caldo de ossos em casa para extrair o
máximo de benefícios do seu caso de
ossos é importante escolher ossos de
animais de alta qualidade priorize ossos
de animais que tenham tido uma
alimentação natural em Pastos evite
ossos de animais confinados e
alimentados com grãos então esses ossos
geralmente podem ser adquiridos em
açougues locais onde você consegue esses
até de forma gratuita pessoal eu vou
então deixar um vídeo na descrição com a
receita passo a passo de como fazer o
caldo de ossos de forma simples mas
vamos falar aqui em modo geral como é
que se faz como é que é o preparo do Cao
de ossos por ossos com articulações como
a paleta o pernil de gado o pernil de
porco osso buco pés e pescoço de galinha
ou cabeça de peixe que são ricos em
colágeno Então os ingredientes básicos
são de 500 g a 1 kg de ossos isso
depende da capacidade da sua panela se
for maior cabe mais uma cebola grande
quatro dentes de alho duas cenouras duas
colheres de sopa de vinagre de maçã uma
colher de sopa de sal integral uma
colher de chá chá de pimenta do reino
moída ervas e especiarias a gosto
Experimente adicionar ervas como louro
tomilho alho gengibre e cúrcuma para
conferir sabores únicos e benefícios à
sua saúde Ajuste as quantidades conforme
as suas preferências então em se
tratando de cozimento o tradicional é
colocar na panela aberta então você pode
colocar os ossos de frango e peixe que
deve ser cozido por 12 horas em fogo
baixo ossos de carne de boi podem ser
cozidos de 24 a 48 horas mas se você não
quiser esperar tanto tempo use a panela
de pressão cozinhe os ossos na panela de
pressão começando com uma hora em fogo
alto Abra a panela com segurança e
continue cozimento aberto por mais du a
3 horas doure os ossos para intensificar
o sabor você pode dourar os ossos do
forno a 200º c por 30 minutos ou na
panela antes de colocar na água que
nesse caso deve estar quente Isso é
opcional Coloque os ossos em uma panela
segura adicione água pura e filtrada o
suficiente para cobrir os ossos adicione
duas colheres de sopa de vinagre de maçã
a água deixe descansar por 30 minutos
para ajudar a extrair os nutrientes dos
Ossos acrescente Os Vegetais e temperos
Secos e leve a fervura reduza para fogo
baixo e remova a espuma que se forma
para um caldo mais claro nos últimos 30
minutos de cozimento adicione o alho
legumes e as especiarias frescas E se
for necessário adicione mais água quente
para manter os ossos cobertos após o
término do cozimento deixa esfriar um
pouco retire os ossos e coe o caldo
deixe esfriar totalmente e uma camada de
gordura se formará na superfície essa
camada vai proteger o caldo que está na
parte de baixo e o mantém gelatinoso
quando refrigerado então retira essa
camada de gordura Apenas quando você for
usar o caldo essa camada pode ser usada
para cozinhar ou mesmo você pode
utilizar essa gordura um pouco dela para
dar sabor na hora de tomar o caldo como
então congelar esse caldo armazenem
frascos eh pequenininhos congele no seu
congelador e pode durar até 6 meses no
freezer na geladeira mantenha por 5 a 7
dias se você não for congelar aqui vai
uma dica você pode pegar esse caldo de
osso colocar naquelas formas de gelo e
colocar diretamente no congelador isso
fica mais conveniente então consuma uma
xícara de caldo de ossos antes do almoço
ou jantar para ter os benefícios nas
articulações use um cubo do caldo ou uma
colher bem cheia de sopa para cada
xícara e é seguro consumir até quatro
colheres de sopa da gelatina por dia
compartilhe os vídeos faça bem a vida de
alguém pode mudar também no canal
do alendo
muito obrigado por ter assistido esse
vídeo até o final um beijo no seu
coração não esqueça de dividir esse
material com seus amigos e familiares é
muito importante pros seus entes
queridos poderem ter uma melhor de
qualidade de vida você é fera